so you're l ron hubbard it's 1950 and
you just resigned from your position in
the navy
during your time in the navy you claim
that you saved your shift from japanese
submarines that you destroyed the sub so
thoroughly there was nothing left for
them to find
you would go on telling everyone about
how you received a purple heart and
other medals for your service in reality
u.s navy investigators concluded that
there were never such japanese subs in
reality it was just stolen valor and now
that you're out of the military you go
on to look for your next path to
greatness it's around this time that you
decide to use your creativity you are a
science fiction writer so you decide to
submit an article to the astounding
science fiction magazine the article was
called dianetics a new science of the
mind later that year you extend the
article into a full-length book and it
blows up you originally wrote dianetics
as a pop psychology book that could help
people improve their daily lives
providing techniques that could take
away pain stress and sickness and help
develop their intelligence and memory
but plans change when you're hit with a
brilliant idea there's a lot of power in
telling people how to fix their lives it
makes them want to give everything they
have to you it's almost a borderline
religion
so what if you could take your book and
turn it into a full-blown religion a
religion that sees you as the prophets
so you get all the attention and praise
that you so desperately need and gets
you the money you need because after all
when you're promising people eternal
afterlife salvation the parting of a few
thousand dollars is a no-brainer that
makes religion the ultimate business
model if you think about it you have the
secret to curing anyone anywhere of
their problems all they have to do to
get the answers is pay and they're happy
to pay and the only way they get to find
out if you're telling the truth or not
is to die you can keep on going down
this path of enlightenment for decades
without ever providing any real proof
and you'll be gaining money every step
of the way since it's a religion no one
can question your actions as immoral or
wrong because it's just a part of our
religious beliefs the outside world
wouldn't understand the thing is that
they they do like the organization does
like to be put in the same sentences as
other you know real churches so that's
actually a good thing because they use
that as like look you know we get made
fun of just like everybody else like you
know we're a real religion so respect us
as a real religion and best of all while
other corporations are still giving away
20 30 of their money to the tax man
you'll never have to pay a single dime
of your billions to taxes religious
organizations and churches are tax
exempt in the u.s it could be
the greatest kind that's ever been
practiced on the public
that's why in 1953 what started as an
article in a science fiction novel
turned into the church of scientology
and it promised to make a positive
difference in the galaxy but when you
pull back the curtain it sheds light on
something much more sinister a
multi-faceted transnational corporation
that has religion as only one of its
many components a business that decades
later would be embraced in murders
worker exploitation harassment and
intimidation and much more
this is the business of scientology
people who fall victim to scientology
usually end up feeling alone in the
world with nobody to turn to for help
but you don't have to be lured in by a
religious cult to feel this way many of
us feel alone in our regular lives if
you're watching this channel you're
probably ambitious with big goals and to
achieve those goals you need to view
yourself as an athlete not necessarily a
physical athlete but a mental one
athletes have coaches physical athletes
have coaches and yet we never think to
have a mental coach someone to help us
sort through the problems we're going
through in our head in fact if you get a
mental coach also known as a therapist
it's even looked down upon by society
but one company changing that stigma is
better help today's video sponsor
better help is the largest therapy
platform in the world with over 2
million users and it's 100 online with
better help you get access to over 20
000 licensed embedded therapists who are
available no matter where you are in the
world it's not a crisis line or
self-help it's professional therapy
that's done securely online and it's
super simple to sign up first you give
better help some information about
yourself and what kind of therapy you're
looking for then based on your personal
needs better help matches you with a
therapist who is the best fit for you
and that's it you start communicating
with your therapist in as little as 48
hours and once you're matched you can
send them a message whenever you want
you can set up weekly video or phone
calls with your therapist and avoid the
awkwardness of in-person sessions and
it's way less stressful than trying to
find a good therapist in your area plus
if you're not really feeling your
therapist it's easy and free to switch
to a new one best of all better help is
more affordable than traditional therapy
and financial aid is available my mental
health is definitely something i'm
prioritizing this year because no amount
of success matters if you've got a bunch
of mental issues that you haven't sorted
out yet so if you're ready to start
taking control of your mental health
today visit betterhelp.com jake tran for
10 off your first month that's better
h-e-l-p
betterhelp.com for 10 off your first
month thanks to better help for
sponsoring this video
let's get my relationship to this
completely straight
so on i am the writer
of the textbooks of scientology in order
to create a religion you have to first
understand the purpose of religion why
do we need it why did it come about well
a long time ago humans were left with a
very important question how do i carry
myself in this world so that i survive
so we started telling tales of heroes
heroes that would go off into the
darkness slay their enemies and bring
back food for the tribe heroes who
wouldn't murder heroes who wouldn't
commit adultery who wouldn't steal etc
however stealing adultery murder are
pretty tempting things to do so we
needed awards and punishment for
following or not following these
societal norms i.e heaven and hell
eternal afterlife or eternal suffering
and over time these hero stories would
keep getting passed on they would keep
iterating over and over again they would
keep getting embellished with
supernatural features until they became
a fine-tuned version of how a culture
wants you to carry yourself these
fine-tuned stories eventually became
religions like christianity islam etc so
whatever religion you create a big part
of it is giving people a sense of
purpose a sense of direction as to how
to live their lives the salvation
they're gonna get by following your
rules and the eternal suffering they'll
receive if otherwise so let's look at
how scientology approach this the term
scientology means the study of truth
it's influenced by elements of several
western philosophies like christianity
along with buddhism hinduism combined
with some practices from cognitive
behavioral therapy
even though l ron hubbard and
scientology denounced all those things
as complete bs
but that's what you want to do when you
start a new religion we already know
religions like christianity and buddhism
have a track record of working for
thousands of years so don't be arrogant
we gotta respect the giants that came
before us and why would you want to
reinvent the wheel borrow their stories
borrow their lessons borrow their
strategies and tactics and then just
repackage it rebrand it make it feel
like a new thing a new opportunity
people are tired of the current
religions they've heard the pitch a
thousand times give them something new
to be excited about when in reality you
and i both know that you just repackaged
a bunch of old stuff
and there's another great thing about
the business of religion what is truth
how are you gonna prove that
christianity is true that hinduism is
true that the quran is true you can't
the only thing that matters is that you
make people feel that they have a
purpose that they're happy that they're
going to a better place after this life
if you achieve that it's all fair game
here's how scientology approach their
messaging scientology urges that we're
not actually our body or our mind our
bodies are just vessels fairly
reasonable that we're actually just
spirits that occupy our current bodies
and that we go on to exist for many
lifetimes
the whole purpose of being here
is to advance you as a spiritual being
and to make your dreams come true
training or processing the basic tenets
of their belief is that man is an
immortal spiritual being your experience
extends beyond a single lifetime and
that your capabilities are unlimited
even if not presently realized doesn't
that just make you feel inspired by just
hearing that they did a really good job
with this part scientology says the main
pain and struggles from our past
lifetimes don't just go away when we die
and they can be seriously holding us
back in this lifetime that's where
scientology can help
the negative stimuli from our past lives
are called engrams and to clear engrams
we conveniently have a series of
processes that are meant to clear them
out once you're free of all this
negativity you're open to reaching your
full potential in this lifetime whatever
that means to you
as a religion maker you create the
problem and you conveniently offer the
solution paywalled behind a donation you
know the downside of our western
societies is that we have so much
freedom so much hyper individualism that
we're left feeling that we don't know
what our purpose is anymore we don't
have a unified collective goal to fight
for so you want to offer that unified
collective goal with your religion
scientologists believe that they're on a
crusade to save the entire planet or
even the entire galaxy the scientology
skills and knowledge are the only things
keeping it all together
i think it's a privilege to call
yourself a scientologist and it's
something that you have to earn
and because scientologist does
he or she has the ability to
create new and better realities and
improve conditions
uh being a scientologist you look at
someone and you know absolutely that you
can help them on their website
scientology says the one thing that sets
them apart from other religions is proof
that you can simply apply the principles
of scientology to your life and witness
the results unfold when in reality the
principles they expound probably come
from the psychology and personal
development world so of course they're
going to work
and they've done very well for
themselves the church claims that there
are over 11 000 scientology churches
missions and affiliate groups in 167
nations across the world 4x more than
where they were 10 years ago however
many sources agree that this number is
grossly over exaggerated and that many
think that scientology membership has
been steadily decreasing since the 90s
whether or not they're getting more new
members one thing that continues to grow
is scientology's bank accounts the
church's estimated revenue is around
half a billion dollars every single year
tom cruise alone has given approximately
25 million dollars to scientology so how
does it all work
[Music]
scientology has become a well-oiled
machine pulling in new members and
keeping them loyal to the church there
are generations of families that have
grown up in scientology with 70
scientology buildings all over the world
here's how the business operates l ron
hubbard has written an absurd amount of
books he's actually published more books
than any other author in the us 1084 to
be exact
if there's something in your life that
you're struggling with l ron hubbard has
written a book to solve that problem if
you're feeling bored with your existence
if you can't stop eating junk food if
you can't get along with your parents l
ron hubbard has written a book for it
and those books have been adapted into
courses that you can take to fix every
little thing wrong with your life it
starts off small scientology pinpoints
your struggle or ruin as they call it
and says hey we just so happen to have a
course for that all it costs is 50
and you think what the heck it couldn't
hurt right when in reality that 50 is
just a hook just a low ticket bait to
get you used to giving the money so you
go to the course that's going to teach
you how to have a successful marriage or
make lots of money but during the course
you find out that there are actually
five other things messed up with your
life things that you never even thought
of before but no worries scientology has
courses for these five problems as well
all for the fair price of five thousand
dollars each and that's how you get
caught in the process of improvements
scientologists continue for years paying
for courses over and over again until
one day they wake up and realize that
they've given the church of scientology
half a million dollars
once you're in scientology a thing
called auditing becomes a big part of
your life we will begin the session now
close your eyes everything that i have
said to you while you're in a therapy
session will be canceled and will have
no force with you auditing is kind of
like talk therapy with a little extra
manipulation
the person being audited speaks with an
auditor and tells them everything i mean
every little detail of this life and of
the past lives you might not even
remember while a subject talks they're
connected to a device called an e-meter
you would be looking at the e-meter you
would ask me a question and then if it
reacted on the meter then you would ask
me more about that question it's kind of
like a lie detectors many people compare
it to a lie detector because it's
supposed to measure your body's
electrical currents
units units dude units of what units of
stress you're very very high it's a lot
of units and you're stressing the
e-meter supposedly tells the auditor
what questions to ask and when the
subject isn't telling them everything
based on these bodily changes every
single one of these sessions is recorded
and it costs an average rate of 500 an
hour and the auditing session doesn't
end until the auditor says so and
members go through hundreds of these
auditing sessions throughout the years
so do the math on that one auditing has
very high margins
every scientologist including children
must participate in auditing sessions
but why would they well they have to if
they want to reach the highest levels of
the religion
you basically disclose everything that
could be of a negative nature which is
the only way to reach the higher levels
to become clean so many people agree to
do it after years of participating in
the church of scientology you might be
lucky enough to be chosen for the sea
org
harper established the sea org in 1967
as a group for only the most dedicated
scientologists in the world the church
claims that there are over 5 000 sea org
members today children who grew up in
scientology are taught that joining the
sea org is the most important thing they
could do in their lives many
scientologist parents sign over custody
of their kids to the church of
scientology just so the kids can join
the sea org as young as 14 years old a
requirement for joining the sea org is
signing a billion year contract yes
that's right a billion years the
contract states that after death you'll
be given 21 years of leave from your sea
org services but you'll be expected to
come back and keep serving the sea org
in your next lifetime
so what's the big important work that
members of the sea org are doing well
they're working for up to 16 hours a day
doing manual labor or anything else
they're told to do if you're in the sea
org you work all the time i mean you're
cleaning out garbage cans you're
sweeping floors you're working you know
14 15 16 hours a day and since they're
volunteering for a religion scientology
can pay these members next to nothing
one ex-scientologist said that he made
more money in the three months after
leaving scientology than he had in 15
years working for the church which
brings us to yet another benefit of the
business of religion slave labor
all the auditing and work for the sea
org gets you to higher levels of
scientology each one brings you closer
to the bridge of total freedom the
utmost goal for scientologists but it
can take many years and cost hundreds of
thousands of dollars to reach this
mystical point of enlightenment
scientology claims that once you reach
this level you can become an operating
thetan or ot ots can allegedly move
objects with their mind control people's
behavior and communicate telepathically
[Music]
[Music]
i was 21 years old
living in london ontario canada
i wanted to be a documentary filmmaker
and someone had told me
about
what they called who said there's this
cult
in new york
called scientology which i'd never heard
of
and if you give them all your money
they'll make anything possible in your
life every single product and service
that scientology provides costs money
it's actually blatantly stated by l ron
hubbard that everything in the religion
should come at a price sure other major
religions may ask their members for
donations but you'll be hard-pressed to
find another one that requires its
members to pay thousands of dollars to
be considered a good scientologist
leah remini said that the 12 basic books
of scientology cost around four thousand
dollars they're updated often so members
must keep buying the new books
your reactive mind is the cause of
what's wrong in your life
but with dianetics
you're going to learn how to get rid of
it
scientology took a page out of the
education industrial complex before you
can reach the bridge of total freedom
there are hundreds of courses that you
need to take that cost around 650 each
the hubbard college of scientology
qualifications division department of
certifications and awards does hereby
certify that anthony a phillips has
attained the state of clear
michelle leclaire another ex-member said
that she gave 5 million to scientology
over the years plus scientology pays a
10 commission to anyone who can bring in
new recruits so if you bring in five new
people you'll get a cut off all the
money they give to scientology and you
gotta give the guys at the church some
credit here not only did they borrow
from other religions cognitive
behavioral therapy the education
business the self-help business but they
also borrowed from the very profitable
multi-level marketing business that is
true innovation and since you just lose
money if you sit on billions of dollars
in cash thanks to inflation the church
of scientology also borrowed the page
out of the catholic church's book and
poured that cash into real estate the
church owes approximately 12 million
square feet of property around the world
scientology has become
a
fundraising and real estate empire
rather than a spiritual religious empire
in addition to the revenue scientology
also has low expenses thanks to the
exploits of free labor many
scientologists like those in the sea org
work for free for decades the max i got
paid
you know on a weekly basis was 50 bucks
sea org workers
take home
something between 6 and 40 cents an hour
so if you've got
very low
labor costs no taxes to pay
and wealthy people giving you donations
you can see why scientology has amassed
huge piles of money the only thing
scientology ever pays for are legal
protection private investigators and the
cost of harassing ex-members they hire
private detectives to harass people i
have been sued twice financial ruin
years of harassment their homes broken
into have been beaten we chased her
around we followed her to the airport
gotten hold of personal phone records
slash their tires break their car
windows i was locked in a chicken wire
cage
in fact the church's biggest expense is
scaring ex-members into keeping their
mouth shut about scientology
[Music]
in 1957 the irs revoked scientology's
tax-exempt status because it was
determined that scientology was a
commercial organization the church spent
the next 25 years playing dirty to fight
back an investigation by the new york
times discovered that scientology had
actually orchestrated a plot to destroy
the lives of individual irs employees
scientology's lawyers hired private
investigators to dig into the private
lives of irs officials and basically
stalk them to uncover potential
vulnerabilities the church even financed
an organization of irs whistleblowers
that attacked the agency publicly
eventually the irs had had enough and
the commissioner agreed to negotiate
with the church can you imagine the irs
agreeing to negotiate with you about
paying your taxes yeah me neither they
came to an agreement and the church of
scientology was granted religious
recognition and tax exempt status by the
irs in 1993. i mean considering that
scientology makes around 500 million
dollars a year that's over a hundred
million dollars they'd be losing to
taxes and scientology successfully
bullied the irs into not paying them
scientology would do anything to hold on
to its tax-exempt status including suing
harassing stalking and slander and even
making someone disappear if that's what
it takes
i knew they had their goons around
and then the guy rolls down his window
and i saw the truck
and he starts filming and i go
okay this is not good what's going on
oh we're just doing a documentary
[Music]
that was a private investigator who's
been following us all night long the
church of scientology is known for
intimidating former members who leave
the church you hear stories about people
leaving scientology and you hear about
them coming to your house and scaring
you and or you know threatening you for
current members of the church discipline
comes in the form of physical punishment
usually from the church's leader david
miscavige you are missing the signpost
up ahead
the one that reads
next stop
infinity many ex-scientologists have
horrible stories about david beating
people we'd be in meetings
and he would punch people in the meeting
on two occasions david miscavige struck
me
and one of the last
occasions was in the 2000s it was
shortly before i left
and he punched me and he basically i had
glasses at the time he punched me so
hard in the face that my glasses broke
did david miscavige ever beat you nearly
many many times
did you witness him beat others many
many many times
scientology also has big consequences in
store for people who dare cross them and
there are no limits to the extent
they'll punish someone who betrays them
i don't know other churches that demand
to destroy people's lives if they leave
and speak out publicly against it i
don't know
real churches who
demand families to break apart if one
feels
uh that they should leave like michelle
leclaire michelle was a member of
scientology for 21 years she was married
to a man and raised four children in the
church but then when she came turns with
the fact that she was a lesbian the
church made her life a nightmare
every time i tried to reach out to the
church
my thoughts of women and my confession
of homosexuality was used against me she
tried to get a divorce and leave
scientology four separate times but they
kept telling her to pay for more courses
and do more work on her marriage but it
wasn't until she threatened to stop
giving the church money that they
finally let her file for divorce
i said if you do not get me out of
session
and start this divorce immediately
you will not get another dime from me
and the next day i was in the chaplain's
office
with a lawyer on the phone writing up
our divorce agreement but they weren't
just gonna let her leave they told the
california department of corporations
that michelle was operating a ponzi
scheme she ended up being indicted and
paying back 1.2 million dollars now
whenever michelle speaks up about
scientology they can just say oh don't
listen to her she's a felon but michelle
claims that the church of scientology
set her up to take the fall after
members leave the church they're labeled
as suppressive people their families are
forced to stop communicating with them
they become completely isolated to
everyone they were close to but still
other members don't even get a chance to
escape scientology like shelley
miscavige the wife of scientology's
leader david miscavige shelley and david
met in the sea org for years they were
the power couple of scientology until
one day she just disappeared without a
trace
shelly has now been missing for the past
15 years some speculate that she's dead
others think she's being held captive by
david in the mountains of los angeles
for all these years do you think he has
the ability the will
to order his wife be locked away
absolutely there's no question about it
it's believed that shelly is being
punished because she defied david by
using a new system with his staff while
he was out of town people who ask about
shelley are always met with aggression
coming here and making it seem dark and
mysterious
thou that does is you create threats
against us
very innocent people why do you like it
when her friend leah remini dared to ask
about her whereabouts she was forced to
undergo intense auditing for four months
and she wasn't allowed to leave until
they were satisfied leah paid three
hundred thousand dollars for the
privilege
who is this guy
what's that guy doing with the phone
right yep yeah look at look at how
they're like pointing they have their
i got the guy with his phone scientology
denies shelley is even missing to this
day nobody has heard from or seen
shelley miscavige since 2007 and david
continues to run the church of
scientology with an iron fist
[Music]
so out of all the things that i've
covered scientology actually actively
goes after people that criticizes them
with the other one being russia who also
goes after people who criticize them so
depending on whether or not you're
seeing this video publicly or in the
private documentary section will be
what decision i made anyways that's
going to wrap it up don't forget to
subscribe if you're seeing this video
publicly click the join button below for
other documentaries that are too
controversial to be posted publicly you
can follow me on instagram at jtrand.io
spelled exactly like that please watch
out for fake accounts i am not going to
message you asking for money that's
going to wrap it up thank you for
watching stay dangerous out there and i
will see you guys in the next one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you